no one is higher on Israel's most wanted
list than this man he's Yaya sinoa
leader of Hamas in Gaza and the person
Israel holds most responsible for the
attacks on October the 7th prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu calls Sina a
dead man walking if they find him
Israeli forces have no intention of
taking sinoa alive Israel has been
killing Hamas figures for decades Hamas
Founders shik ahed Yasin and Abdul aiz
Al rantis were assassinated in
2004 dozens of other Hamas commanders
and leaders have met similar Fates over
the years part of a wider campaign
against several Palestinian groups
there's a sense that they can kind of
weaken the Palestinians um and eliminate
their leaders and keep them kind of
defeated and divided but you know we've
seen that that those policies those
violent policies haven't worked in you
know in suppressing Palestinians General
desire for freedom from
occupation they also haven't suppressed
Hamas or its military Wing the kasan
brigades they not only endured on
October 7th Hamas Fighters Unleashed an
attack on a scale it had never
previously attempted Hamas deceived
Israel's intelligence and overwhelmed
its distracted military Israel says
1,400 people mostly civilians were
killed and more than 200 taken captive
Israel's long-standing policy is
it no longer is willing just to blockade
Hamas in and pick off its leaders its
stated aim is now the group's complete
destruction and it's destroying Gaza in
the process that is complicating
Israel's other aim returning its
captives The Dilemma is very clear if
you uh keep uh uh pomping and uh running
after the uh Hamas everywhere including
in the tunnels uh you cannot avoid also
killing your own people the
hostages as bombs rain down and Israeli
troops push deep into Gaza more than
11,000 Palestinians have so far perished
in the smoking
Rubble Israel's targeted assassination
policy has become a failed relic of a
previous age but gaza's Palestinians
feel they may as well all be on Israel's
assassination list now Rory chalins
aler